[Musique]
on est loin du premier vol de gagarine
il ya soixante concerts à jeu lumière le
cosmodrome de baïkonour est
méconnaissable
la russie a vraiment mis le paquet pour
ce lancement hors du commun de la fusée
soyouz connais mon shopping et ue les
pellicules le réalisateur clint penco et
sa muse l'actrice julia pelles et ses
hommes seront les tout premiers de
l'histoire à s'envoler pour tourner un
film de fiction non
il avait l'air drôlement calme lundi
matin en conférence de presse la
dernière sur terre avant le grand départ
thirau agx culte ce jour une physique
jusqu'à ce jour
mais la vérité c'est que nous sommes
tous épuisés dit elle
l'entraînement s'est avéré une épreuve
psychologique et physique intense et
brutale elle n'aura eu que quatre mois
on va prendre vivement du
médecin-explorateur de l'est
grande star du cinéma russe connu pour
ses films à succès et à saveur
patriotique hulya pellicer désormais une
héroïne nationale
le nouveau symbole russe de la course à
l'espace
le projet est un partenariat entre
l'agencé spatiale russe roskosmos un
grand studio de cinéma et la principale
chaîne de télévision publique qui
diffuse depuis des semaines d émission
style téléréalité question d'alimenter
le suspense et les coulisses des
éditions de centaines de femmes parmi
lesquelles pdcirda été choisi pour sa
forme physique qui son sang froid
le cosmonaute sergueï volkov en sait
quelque chose pour avoir passé presque
un an à bord de la station spatiale
apprivoiser la pesanteur n'est pas
acquis pour tout le monde encore moins
pour y faire du cinéma là-haut à 400 km
de la terre
la station spatiale internationale sera
leur plateau de tournage et les
cosmonautes qu'il occupe déjà souvent
les figurants l'histoire du film sera
celle d'une médecin ordinaire qui doit
enfiler d'urgence une combinaison
spatiale il s'envolait vers la station
pour sauver la vie d'un cosmonaute qui
est trop malade pour revenir sur terre
alors les intrigues fois qu'elle chante
on s'entend n'était pas la première
motivation des russes il se sent chez
lui tard ce prix après
igo comme pichon l'expert est
journaliste anatoli zach duke la russie
se paie un caprice d'orgueil aux frais
des contribuables pour damer le pion aux
américains puisque la nasa avait annoncé
au mois de mai qu'elle allait faire le
premier film en orbite avec spacek ce
est nul autre que tom cruise
grande amie depuis l'émission est aussi
des
gens
alors de la commercialisation des vols
et du tourisme spatial c'est une bonne
chose dit l'astronaute canadien robert
et l'autre
avec ce vol julij après s'il se joint
une nouvelle corde explorateurs amateurs
et si la russie lui offre le voyage
c'est aussi pour se tailler une place
compétitive un genre d'appels d'offres
de bureaux
japanese de racheter notre caméra
de
cinéma russe aurait pu évidemment se
contenter d'un simulateur et des effets
spéciaux du metteur en scène dont les
films faut parmi les plus rentables dans
les salles en russe mais c'était une
occasion en or de franchir une nouvelle
trottier je voulais plus il permet
toujours de tournage en orbite pour
filmer des scènes clé une mission
artistique à la gloire de la russe